well as we gear up for the conservative
party conference let's find out what the
most important people you at home make
of everything that's going on at the
moment just how worried our viewers
panel is uh here you all are thank you
very much for being with us at this
evening it's great to see everybody here
well let's crack straight on shall we go
to Ian first we're going to talk to Ian
Michael John first a labor voter you're
talking to us from Newbury in what do
you make of you know the interviews that
we've heard so far the government says
that they are not going to change their
course
well it's absolutely fascinating that uh
the conservative party the government is
the only one in Step the rest of the
world has got it wrong hasn't understood
what they're doing and the run on the
pound is obviously some terrible mistake
it's not it's awful it's Dreadful it's
frightening and whatever
budgetary benefit there may be for uh
the ordinary working person by way of
tax cuts is quite likely to be eaten up
by increased mortgages by the cost of
living by General inflation much of
which it seems May well be caused by
this particular budget
okay so Ian unhappy with a with a
thought that the government wants to
continue with its plan let's get the
view of Vic Daniels now shall we
conservative photo you're talking to us
from West London are you pleased that
the government is sticking to its plans
um please I'm confident and I'm
motivated Sophie
um you know I run a small business 120
130 people totally demotivated about the
increases of National Insurance and also
the proposed increase in corporation tax
um over the last five days we've got
more jobs out for higher than ever
before we're all in stock in Step we're
all motivated uh and we all want to work
harder work longer get more people on
the payroll make more money pay more tax
employ more people and ensure that
there's more money available to to the
public services so as a small business
person I'm in a very good place at the
moment really interesting to hear a
different perspectives on this both of
you very energized for different reasons
right let's go to is our shall we this
is ISA battachary you are 27 years old
which is why I want to talk to you
because obviously the increase borrowing
some would say is going to be people
like yourselves who might be paying that
off
yeah it's frustrating that during a
period of kind of record low interest
rates the government cared about fiscal
discipline and it was all about keeping
the balance the budget balance but now
as soon as rates are starting to go up
the government is like happy to spend on
all sorts of kind of tax cuts largely
for the rich which are not even going to
be very effective at stimulating growth
well interesting and do you do you not
think though that some people are saying
that actually it will stimulate the
economy that's the argument we heard
from Chris philp he said that it's all
about growth that helps everyone because
it helps people create jobs and it helps
Drive wages up
well I think if you look at the data so
the IMF did a massive report in 2015
that showed that actually these kind of
tax cuts just increase inequality and
they don't stimulate very much growth
and if they do it's very very narrow I
think realistically there were a whole
bunch of things they could have done to
stimulate growth the highest effective
tax rate is actually for those who are
on the Universal Credit earnings taper
which is a 55 tax rate they could have
looked at that they could have looked at
things like child care to improve labor
force participation which massively
tanked during the pandemic and hasn't
really recovered since so it's actually
just frustrating to see that they've
opted for a policy that doesn't really
have any evidence well let's see what
happens at the next policy review shall
we really interesting to hear your
thoughts thanks very much is our let's
get Chloe's view next we can talk to
Chloe who is our nurse you're talking to
us from Cumbria now I've got you down on
my sheet as conservative because she
voted conservative at the last election
but it's fair to say that you've been
wavering a bit since then
yeah I think from seeing the labor
conference as well
um they're a lot more in touch aren't
they with the regular working person I
mean the mini budget they need to get
rid of that completely and we've now got
the chancellor that doesn't you know he
has no comment when he's questioned
about it and we've got a prime minister
that has been nowhere to be seen and
which doesn't really give you much Faith
um
in any of this really and I think I mean
I've spoken to people just today who
have then said you know like one of my
friends she's got a 500 pound gas and
electric bill so you know they have to
go you have to go to work more to pay
your bill there's then higher for you
not to be there because you're having to
go to work more and one of my other
friends today he said he's really
concerned about the interest rates on
his mortgage so he's the same you know
he's now really concerned about having
to go to work more you know not even
being in the house that is having to pay
more for and I think it's a really a
really frightening time and I think
um it's really going to start affecting
people's mental health as well I think
there'll be a massive increase
in in things like that I'm just Keen to
talk a little bit at the end thank you
very much Chloe about at Labor
conference and just to get people's
views I guess on what they made of you
know kirst armor and labor conference
more wider we can let's talk to Stella
shall we uh Stella Findlay you're
talking to us from Newcastle you
describe yourself as a green or a lib
Dem voter what did you make of kirst
armor
um well I wasn't too impressed with Kia
starmer
um I think his delivery was as though
he'd learned a speech and
um there wasn't very much passion or
enthusiasm there
um and I think a lot of the promises
that he made
are not promises that you can keep so I
don't think that we can really trust
what he's going to do in the future
um but what I find more worrying is
about
um the conservatives who I think are
even worse than Kirsten his
um cabinet that um they don't accept
responsibility for the effects of that
many budget and if they accept a
responsibility that it has had that
effect and then said what the future is
going to hold and that the future might
be better for us instead of just
disappearing and not saying anything
about it then we might have more
confidence in the government but it's
very worrying that
and I don't feel we can trust the labor
party not a great situation for you to
be in there Stella well let's go to our
swing voter now at shall we uh this is
Belinda Campbell you're talking to us
from uh Twickenham in South West London
swing voter convinced by case Dharma
I do think they all put on big adverts
for themselves sorry to say that and um
you wonder why they haven't done any of
these things before
um they want to take each other's place
um I thought it was quite passionate and
there's a lot of clapping and you want
to believe that it's all going to happen
and it's all truthful and you know
govern with Integrity he said so I want
to believe it I really do and
um
all of us just want to feel more secure
because it is frightening I just got a
text from my sister in Switzerland and
she said you know I'm so worried and I'm
thinking of you all there so people are
very worried and um with you know the
lady just said about mental health I
mean that all started in the lockdown
people's mental health was compromised
work worrying time slightly thank you so
much indeed uh always a pleasure to talk
to you guys so we do appreciate you
giving up a little chunk of your
Wednesday night thank you very much